there's so many groups out there that
purport to be helping veterans the
impulse is honorable it's great of
course not all the groups are great
however so we wanted to highlight the
work of a group we think is great and a
man who's devoted his life to helping
members of the military and their
families frank siller is the founder of
tunnel to towers foundation
the organization provides mortgage-free
homes for the families of combat
veterans who died fighting for the
country as well as veterans who are
seriously injured we're happy to have
frank ziller join us tonight frank
thanks so much for coming on so this has
totally taken over your time in your
life this is what you're doing with your
life tell us why you've decided to do
this and thank you by the way well
thanks for having me on and listen my
whole family decided to do this because
20 years ago our youngest brother a
firefighter steven gerrard silla
gave up his life uh he ran through the
brooklyn battery tunnel with
60 pounds of fire gear on his back
to get to the towers going up the stairs
saving other people and while doing so
he gave up his life and we made a
promise as a family to make sure we
never forgot and since that day we've
lost 7 000 70 men and women in uniform
who have been protecting us here on our
homeland and we better never forget
those uh great heroes and today we're so
proud that we read all of those names
7070 at the lincoln memorial these gold
star families were with us reading their
loved ones names out and it was uh very
very moving and very necessary it was
the right thing to do so we're very
proud 7 000 i don't think most americans
understand
the magnitude of that so you part of
what you do is give homes to the
families
of
servicemen killed in in action
what is the response to that i mean
that's such a remarkable thing to do
yes we gave out 35 mortgage-free homes
today to gold star families 35. this
year alone we're doing 200. now you
could do the math tucker that's a big
number but we have fox viewers have been
helping us for years thank goodness
and we've been able to accomplish this
because of the generosity of great
americans look it's something the
reaction is thank god uh
they thank us because they could stay in
their homes uh that they were making the
dreams with their loved ones and if they
didn't have a home because a lot of
these service members go from base to
base and don't have one we we build them
a mortgage-free home so they're so
grateful because everyone we do for has
a young family uh left behind and i
think it's
the least that we could do as a country
to take care of these families that put
it all on the line for us and so many
times they don't come home they're
willing to die for you and i every day
tucker and so many times they do and we
better take care of them as a nation and
at tuttle the towers foundation we just
want to be that conduit to bring
americans together to take care of these
families i agree with that completely
final question i have to ask does it
wear you out
emotionally no it doesn't okay no no it
is so uplifting so gratifying and i love
these families they love our foundation
we bring them into our
our
we just love them if you if you if
you're with us you would see what's
happening all these families that get
these mortgage-free homes they join us
on the mission they want to help the
next uh family they want to pay it
forward so it is quite remarkable it is
something that is divine
intervention and uh but we can't do
without the generosity of of americans
we know uh we are the land of the free
because of the brave but we better take
care of the brave when they don't come
home at least take care of the families
uh that are left behind and that is our
promise forever the tunnel to towers
foundation has made that commitment we
ask an awful lot of these people i agree
with you completely frank silva thank
you very much tunnel to towers thanks
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else